I never thought I'd make it to the
finals I mean there's so many amazing
dancers in this competition but we gave
it our all
and to be here it's thanks to the fans
it's thanks to Canada as well we had a
whole country behind us but it was the
most fun I've had in so long
the property brother leaving the show
with his highest score of the season
getting three perfect tens and a nine
for his freestyle dance it was really
embodying both of our personalities in
one dance and I love the fun that Emma
put into choreography and the lifts and
the tricks and the laughing of the joke
Keaney it was amazing joking aside the
routine was beaten out by Frankie Muniz
and Witney Carson who will go through to
the finale tonight on City TV along with
Jordan Fisher and Lindsey Stirling who
guest judge Julianne Hough is cheering
on Jordan and Lindsey's Charleston was
amazing and then I really loved that
last freestyle that Mark and Lindsey
just did
but honestly all of them have something
special and unique to offer and while
drew lost out on the title he gained
something else partner Emma Slater thank
you so much to me
no you mate you make the best friends on
the show but this is definitely a
special drew can now focus on planning
the first stands for his upcoming
Italian wedding to longtime partner
Linda fan as for those dancing shoes
would Jonathan slip them on everyone
keeps asking if Jonathan's gonna do the
show next season I don't know Jonathan
hmm get in there I did it how about you
do it brother versus brother